♪
STEVE: FOX NEWS EXCLUSIVE
FOOTAGE SHOWS A SURGE OF FOOTAGE
RIO GRANDE, TEXAS THE SHERIFF
SAYS IT'S NEVER BEEN WORSE.
>> TIME TO RESOURCES.
IT'S FRUSTRATING BECAUSE THERE
ARE NO ANSWERS BEING GIVEN.
IT'S NOT I DON'T BELIEVE THAT
THERE IS A PLAN IN PLACE.
RIGHT NOW, YOU KNOW, WE NEED
MORE MANPOWER.
WE NEED PEOPLE IN D.C. TO MAKE A
DECISION, DO THEIR JOB.
STEVE: DO THEIR JOB.
HERE TO REACT THE GUY WHO DID
THE JOB FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR AND
FORMER ACTING ICE DIRECTOR TOM
HOMAN.
TOM, GOOD MORNING.
>> GOOD MORNING.
STEVE: THE VIDEOS FROM OUR
REPORTER BILL MELUGIN DOWN THERE
SHOWED THESE LARGE GROUPS OF
LIKE 30, 40, 50 PEOPLE, A COUPLE
OF THEM, GROUPS OF PEOPLE FROM
CUBA AND VENEZUELA AS WELL AND
THEY ARE JUST WALKING ACROSS AT
THE LOWEST TIME OF THE RIVER AND
THE BORDER PATROL PEOPLE AND THE
SHERIFF'S DEPUTIES ARE RIGHT
THERE HELPING THEM.
REMEMBER THE OLD DAYS WHEN
BORDER PATROL WOULD STAND ON ONE
SIDE AND SAID NO, TURN AROUND.
GO THE OTHER WAY.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
WHEN I WAS A BORDER PATROL
AGENT.
THEY EITHER RAN FROM YOU AND
THEY HID FROM YOU.
THIS IS UNBELIEVABLE WHERE WE
ARE AT AS A NATION.
LOOK, THEY HAVE BEEN INVITED,
RIGHT?
JOE BIDEN MADE PROMISES THEY
WON'T BE DEPORTED.
THEY WON'T BE DETAINED.
THEY GET FREE HEALTHCARE.
IS HE GOING TO SHUT DOWN ICE.
I MEAN, THESE PEOPLE WERE
INVITED AND THEY ARE COMING.
WHAT'S REALLY IRRITATING, STEVE,
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION KNOWS
HOW TO STOP THIS.  JOE BIDEN WAS
VICE PRESIDENT 14, 15 DURING THE
FIRST SURGE.
MAYORKAS WAS THE DEPUTY
SECRETARY.
I MET WITH THESE MEN MANY TIMES.
THEY KNOW HOW WE STOPPED THEM.
DO YOU KNOW HOW WE STOPPED THEM?
WE BUILT DETENTION CENTERS WE
DETAINED THEM LONG ENOUGH TO SEE
A JUDGE.
GOT REMOVAL TOWARDS REMOVE THEM
THE NUMBERS WENT DOWN.
RELEASE THEM AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE WITHOUT SEEING A COURT.
NOT EVEN GETTING A COURT DATE.
GETTING A BRAND NEW CELL PHONE
AND SMART PHONE COMPLEMENTS OF
THE TAXPAYERS.
COURT DATE.
ICE CAN'T REMOVE IMMIGRATION
OFFENDERS ANYMORE.
STEVE: TOM, MAYORKAS ON FRIDAY
SAID THE BORDER IS CLOSED.
YOU LOOK AT THOSE IMAMS, THE
BORDER IS NOT CLOSED.
AND IT'S A CRISIS.
BUT IT IS ALSO AN INVASION.
>> LOOK, THEY ARE TOUTING GREAT
SUCCESS WE HAVE GOT IT UNDER
CONTROL.
LIKE I SAID WEEKS AGO, THEY ARE
GETTING REALLY GOOD AT RELEASING
PEOPLE AS QUICK AS POSSIBLE SO
IT DOESN'T SEEM TO BE
OVERCROWDING AT THE BORDER
PATROL FACILITIES.
MEANWHILE, THEY ARE IGNORING THE
BORDER AND THE THOUSANDS COMING
ACROSS EVERY DAY.
THEY THEIR ACTIONS SPEAK LOUDER
THAN THE WORDS.
PEOPLE IN CENTRAL AMERICA AND
ALL THE WORLD GET TO THE UNITED
STATES, GET RELEASE NOD COURT
DATE AND INTERIOR ENFORCEMENT
HAS BEEN GUTTED.
ICE WILL NEVER REMOVE YOU
BECAUSE YOU HAVE TO COMMIT AN
AGGRAVATED FELONY FOR ICE TO
EVEN LOOK AT YOU THIS.  IS OPEN
BORDERS AGENDA.
THIS IS OPEN BORDERS.
AND THIS IS WHAT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION MEANT THIS.  IS
BY DESIGN.
THIS ISN'T BY ACCIDENT.
STEVE: YOU WERE TALKING ABOUT
YOU MET WITH MAYORKAS MANY, MANY
TIMES.
SOMEBODY THAT PEOPLE MAY NOT BE
FAMILIAR WITH IS A WOMAN BY THE
NAME OF NATALIE WHITE HOUSE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR POLITICAL
STRATEGY AND OUTREACH AND IT IS
A LITTLE OUTRAGEOUS,
ACTUALLY SOME OF THE THINGS SHE
TWEETED IN THE PAST.
FOR INSTANCE SHOW TWEETED THIS
ADMINISTRATION'S ACTIONS ARE NOT
MOTIVATED BY PUBLIC SAFETY
CONCERNS.
THEY ARE TERRORIZING IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES.
ICE DIDN'T EXIST 15 YEARS AGO.
IT DOESN'T HAVE TO EXIST NOW SHE
IS TALKING ABOUT ICE.
AND THEN ABOUT A MONTH LATER IN
2018 SHE SAID IF YOU ARE LOOKING
FOR A WAY TO HELP, LOOK UP YOUR
NEAREST ICE OFFICE AND SHUT IT
DOWN.
TOM THOSE ARE THE WORDS OF A
WHITE HOUSE ADMINISTRATION
OFFICIAL.
>> NEWS FLASH, ICE EXISTED
PRIOR.
IT WAS CALLED THE IMMIGRATION
NATURALIZATION SERVICE.
WE WERE ENFORCING IMMIGRATION
LAW PRIOR TO ICE.
GUESS WHAT?
SHE DOESN'T UNDERSTAND WHAT ICE
EVEN DOES.
SHE PROBABLY GOT THE JOB BECAUSE
OF THAT TWEET.
DOES SHE REALIZE ARRESTED TERM
HOMICIDES, SEIZED
1 MILLION POUNDS OF NARCOTICS.
ARRESTED OVER 1 MILLION CHILD
PREDATORS THAT SAVED OVER 3,000
CHILDREN.
DO THEY REALIZE SAVED 800 WOMEN
HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
SEIZED 7,000 WEAPONS.
SHE HAS NO IDEA WHAT ICE DOES.
SHE PROBABLY GOT THE JOB BECAUSE
SHE HATES ICE JUST LIKE THE VICE
PRESIDENT COMPARED ICE TO THE
KKK.
THAT'S HOW THEY GOT THEIR JOB.